let me share some Reflections on
situations like this and what I did to
better cope with them so first of all
often I strongly failed that I somehow
got treated unfairly but the person from
whom I'm got this feedback got it all
wrong but in the end you need to realize
that all of this doesn't matter there's
a saying that goes perception is reality
in these kinds of feedback situations
there isn't usually much value in trying
to argue about the reality trying to
argue about the facts because the
problem is the perception that the other
person has about the situation this
perception is the reality for the person
and of course this reality might be very
different from the reality that you are
perceiving